بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
والصلاه والسلام على اشرف الانبياء
والمرسلين سيدنا محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين
صاحب الجلاله الملك عبد الله الثاني بن
الحسين ملك المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه في السمو المعالي
الحضور الكريم السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
يطيب لبدايه ان انقل لكم تحياتي مقام سيدي
خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز ال سعود وسيد صاحب سمو الملكي
الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال
سعود ولي العهد الرئيس مجلس الوزراء حفظهم
الله
ويسرني ان اتقدم بالشكر الجديد لجلاله
الملك عبد الله الثاني ابن الحسين ملك
المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه الشقيقه
الاستضافه مؤتمر بغداد للتعاون والشراكه
في نسخته الثانيه وعلى الدعوه الكريمه وما
لقيناه من حفاوه الاستقبال يكرم الضيافه
كما اعربوا عن تقدير المملكه لجهوده فخامه
الرئيس كرون رئيس الجمهوريه الفرنسيه
ومشاركته في رعايه هذا المؤتمر
واود ان اعرب عن شهاده المملكه بالاراده
السياسيه لدى جمهوريه العراق والمتمثله في
عزم دوله رئيس الوزراء محمد شياع السوداني
على مواجهه التحديات وتكريس الامن
والاستقرار لتحقيق طموحاته وتطلعات الشعب
العراقي الشقيق
المملكه وقوفها جنبا الى جنب مع العراق
التنمويه واستعاده مكانته التاريخيه ارضنا
الحضاره والعلم والمعرفه وانهوض به الى
مرحله جديده تقدموا مصلحه الوطنيه فيها
على اي اعتبارات اخرى اصحاب الجلاله
والمعاني من اجتماعنا اليوم يؤكدوا رغبه
المشتركه والصادقه لدولنا الاستمرار وتيره
التعاون والدعم لجمهوريه العراق
وترجمتها الى اشتراكات فعليه تحقق نتائج
في سبيل لدعم مسيره العراق الاقتصاديه
والتنمويها
يرتباطا وثيقا لنبات
ورخاء جيرانها والمنطقه يا جماعه
وان رؤيه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
المستقبليه تهدف لخير بلدان المنطقه
والعالم كما تؤكد المملكه الاعتزامها
المضي قدما في تفعيل وتسريع خطط العمل
المشتركه تحت مظله مجلس التنسيق السعوديه
والعراقي والعمل مع الحكومه العراقيه لفتح
افاق جديده بالتعاون وتعزيز الفرص
الاستثماريه الواعده للشركات ودعوتها الى
توسيع نشاطاتها في البلديه في مجالات
الطاقه المتجدده النظيفه وتحليه المياه
والزراعه وغيرها من المجالات وتشكل مبادره
المملكه الشرق الاوسط الاخضر والسعوديه
الخضراء وانشره الحزام الاخضر بالعراق
مجالها من مجالات التعاون المهمه والتي
تهدف لتعزيز الشراكين كما يتعاون والبلدان
من خلال الاشتراكاتهما في منطقه في منظمه
الدول المصدره
وكذلك في مجموعته من اجل الحفاظ على
الاستقرار اسواق النفط العالميه
المملكه جهود ومشاريع اعاده اعمار العراق
وتفعيل مشاريع الربط
الكهربائيات التي اطلقها مجسول الاعمال
السعوديه والعراقي ومن اهمها مبادره انشاء
مركز بيانات الفرص والحلول والقرارات التي
تخدم مجتمع الاعمال في الجانبين واقامه
الملتقى اقتصاديا سنوي اضافه الى مبادره
القوافل التجاريه المتخصصه بين البلديه
وتنظر المملكه بتقدير
للعراق في تدعيم الممكنات التنميه
والتعاون الاقليمي مما ينعكس الاجابه باذن
الله على رخاء الشعب العراقي
جمهوريه العراق ان المملكه تؤكد على رفضه
اي اعتداء على اي شبر من اراضي العراق
كما تؤكد على وقوفها صفه واحده معلش شقه
في العراق في محاربه الارهاب والتطرف وكل
من يسع للدمار والخراب وثالث
وترحبوا المملكه في هذا السياق باستعاده
العراقي لدوره الايجابي البناء لتعميق
الثقه الثقه والشراكه والسلم الاقليميه
ودوليه وفي الختام لا يسعني الا ان نجدد
تاكيدا المملكه وايمانها الكامل بقدره
العراق على النهوض ورسم مستقبله بما
يتناسب ومع مكانته العريقه العربيه
والاسلاميه والعالميه مستندا على ما لديه
من ثروات طبيعيه وكفاءات بشريه وموروه
حضاريا عريقه والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته